[Musique]
Natacha Poloni, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Vous
connaissez ?
Oui, je connais. Bien sûr que je
connais, je regarde.
C'est vrai ?
Bah oui.
C'était quoi la dernière ?
Euh la dernière que j'ai regardé,
c'était un replay. C'était un replay de
Denis Robert parce que je voulais revoir
tout ce qu'il avait raconté euh sur
Clearstream, sur tous ces trucs-là dans
la mesure où je devais on le recevait
sur euh les terriens du dimanche et je
voulais me remettre en tête un petit peu
tout ce qui est tout son travail.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
succintement
Natacha Poloni
depuis le mois de septembre directrice
de la rédaction de Marianne et je pense
que c'est déjà suffisamment
un défi pour que il y ait pas besoin
d'ajouter autre chose.
Combien de personnes à Marianne ?
À Marianne, on a une soixantaine de
personnes. On a environ 35 cartes de
presse, ce qui est tout petit pour un
hebdomadaire. C'est minuscule. Vous
voyez à l'express en je sais pas 120 ou
130 des cartes de presse.
Budget de fonctionnement, c'est combien
? Ouh ! Alors là, me demandez pas les
chiffres de je ne les ai absolument pas
en tête. Je j'ai vu j'ai étudié tous les
tableaux et tout, mais c'est le genre de
truc que je retiens pas par cœur.
Quand quand vous a vous avez pris la
direction euh est-ce que vous avez été
contesté ? Est-ce que vous avez eu des
problèmes pour vous insérer dans les
équipes déjà présentes ? Est-ce qu'il y
a eu des tensions ? Est-ce que vous avez
été à Doubé tout de suite ?
On n'est jamais adbé tout de suite et
très honnêtement, enfin tout le monde le
sait, euh je ça n'a pas été facile. Ma
nomination n'a pas été évidente et
simple. Voilà, c'est après est-ce que
j'ai été contesté à l'intérieur de la
rédaction ? Moins que ce qui a été dit,
beaucoup moins. C'est-à-dire que en
fait,
pour le dire simplement,
le nouvel actionnaire puisque Marianne
en fait a été racheté, Marianne a subi
un dépôt de bilan. C'est un journal qui
a souffert. Marianne avait subi un dépôt
de bilan et puis ensuite a été vendu à
un nouvel actionnaire Daniel
Schrettinski donc qui a fondé qui a un
groupe CMI qui est un groupe de médias
et qui a racheté donc différents médias
en France et le premier c'était donc
Marianne. Bon il a choisi de me mettre à
la tête de Marianne parce que il a
estimé que j'étais celle qui connaissait
le mieux l'identité de Marianne, ce
qu'était Marianne parmi les gens
potentiellement. Oui, parce que parce
que moi j'ai j'ai commencé à Marianne,
j'ai passé 7 ans là-bas comme
journaliste. Même quand j'en suis parti,
c'est resté ma vraie maison. C'est resté
Je connais ce journal par cœur. Je sais
exactement ce que voulait faire
Jean-François Cann comme journal. Je ne
prétends pas réussir à faire exactement
ça, mais je suis la philosophie qui est
celle qui a été instaurée au départ. Et
c'est pour ça que Schrettinski m'a pris
m'a prise alors même que je ne suis pas
forcément sur sa ligne idéologique mais
il y avait une logique. Logique.
D'après ce que je peux en connaître,
c'est quelqu'un qui est profondément
européen mais qui estime qu'on peut
contester l'Union européenne telle
qu'elle est au nom d'un idéal européen.
Mais il est très clairement
libéral et même plutôt comment dire
plutôt
favorable au système économique tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui. So disons-le
clairement c'est qu'il pensent que la
mondialisation est bénéfique. Donc vous
voyez qu'on n'est pas exactement sur la
même ligne mais moi j'apprécie que
quelqu'un puisse comprendre que ces
idées ne sont pas forcément les bonnes à
la tête d'un journal. Marianne est un
journal très spécifique qui est à la
fois libéral mais antinéolibéral
qui est un journal qui est profondément
républicain qui est en en effet européen
mais qui ne s'est jamais interdit au
contraire de critiquer l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle est qui mais
qui estime que la France peut pas
exister toute seule. En revanche, il
faut des règles et des règles
démocratiques. C'est ça l'esprit de
Marianne.
Votre liberté, elle s'arrête où chez
Marianne ?
Euh pour l'instant euh elle s'arrêtera
le jour où euh on décidera que je n'ai
pas rempli ma mission.
Votre liberté euh votre ligne éditorial,
les sujets que vous traitez, est-ce que
vous avez euh un champ totalement libre
?
Écoutez, un simple exemple, on a fait
une une sur euh Bernard Arnaud et la
fondation Louis Vitton. On a sorti le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
montrait comment euh la fondation Louis
Vuitton avait utilisé la niche Messena.
pour en fait que le contribuable paye la
très grande majorité de cette de ce
bâtiment et de toute son fonctionnement.
Et donc on a expliqué exactement comment
le la cour des comptes ravageait
totalement cette ce mode de
fonctionnement et critiquait à boulet
rouge. Donc on l'a faite la une sur
Bernard Arnaud. On a eu aucune reprise
par nos confrères. Je le déplore. Je ne
sais pas pourquoi la FP n'a pas trouvé
que ça valait une dépêche, mais nous
nous l'avons fait et je n'ai eu aucune
remarque de mon actionnaire qui de toute
façon ne me fait pas de remarque, ne
m'appelle pas. Donc
oui, il vous appelle pas. On va on va
parler d'un sujet d'ailleurs qui fait
l'actualité depuis 3 jours. La Ligue du
LOL. C'est quoi la Ligue du LOL ? Alors
là, très honnêtement, je trouve ce sujet
absolument
euh à la fois
réateur de la boboerie parisienne
journalistique.
Oui, c'est ça. À la fois euh ridicule,
hypertrophié et en même temps
révélateur. Voilà, c'estàd que je pense
que le
cela révèle un mode de fonctionnement
chez certains membres d'une petite élite
médiatique.
Si pas si petite que ça, non ? Oh,
visiblement euh assez euh visiblement
assez large, mais enfin, vous savez euh
c'est un petit monde quand même hein, le
journalisme parisien, ça reste un petit
monde. Je pense que ça ne concerne pas
vraiment euh les citoyens français et
très honnêtement, je pense qu'ils s'en
foutent complètement. Alors que
aujourd'hui ça explose à la figure de
ceux qui ont voulu s'amuser avec ça.
Bon, c'est assez drôle mais pour moi,
c'est totalement anecdotique un truc
comme ça. C'est anecdotique le fait que
depuis 2009, il y a des groupes cachés
qui essayent d'influencer la ligne
éditoriale, les sujets, qui essayent de
faire terire des gens, qui harcellent
des gens, qui harcèlent des des des
femmes qui vont même jusque
sur leur lieu de travail, qui leur
mettent la pression, qui leur empêchent
l'avancement, qui
Oui, je trouve ça enfin je évidemment
que c'est insupportable et que ces gens
sont des terroristes intellectuels, mais
du terrorisme intellectuel, il y en a
dans beaucoup de domaines. C'est une des
dimensions de ce terrorisme
intellectuel. J'ai l'impression que
aujourd'hui on s'en émeux parce que ça a
visé des femmes, des militantes
féministes. Euh et en effet, c'est
dégueulasse ce qui leur avait été fait.
C'est absolument dégueulasse, pathétique
et abjecte. Mais ce terrorisme
intellectuel, ces espèces de petites
côeries, cette façon de faire terire des
sujets, de se coopter entre soi, hélas
ça existe et ça existe dans d'autres
domaines et ça existe vis-à-vis d'autres
cibles que des militantes féministes ou
des
des exemples. Je veux dire, vous vous
avez dans dans le journalisme
certaines idées qui sont mal portées que
on efface bah pendant des années par
exemple d'ailleurs je pense qu'on en
avait déjà parlé ici les sur les
questions économiques.
Il faisait quand même très mauvais être
un journaliste plutôt
critique de la mondialisation en faveur
d'une forme de protectionnisme.
les réseau de pouvoir par exemple comme
vous quand vous avez questionné
Christine sur le siècle euh sur le
Builderberg, j'avais questionner
Christine Krin sur le Bilderberg,
ce qui me semblait normal pour une
raison simple. Je suis je suis
absolument pas d'un naturel complotiste.
Moi, je suis profondément rationnelle.
Ma question vis-à-vis de Christine
Crent, c'était de savoir si un
journaliste a sa place dans un lieu dans
lequel il est interdit de raconter ce
que l'on voit. Qu'est-ce qu'un
journaliste vient chercher là ? C'était
ma simple question. Après, je ne lui
demandais pas si le Bilderberg dirigeait
le monde en cachette, en sous-main et
cetera. Pas du tout. C'est une question
de journaliste à journaliste parce que
je pense qu'il faut se questionner sur
notre rôle. Bon voilà, c'était tout et
euh donc il me semble que mais ce genre
de sujet me semble plus important. La
question de savoir si on peut mener des
enquêtes économiques, si on peut euh
parler de la réalité du pays me semble
plus importante que des affaires de de
côerie sordide entre journalistes
parisiens.
Non, mais une côerie sordide dans le
milieu de la pêche à la ligne, ça va.
Mais une côerie sordide sur le bouton
nucléaire du journalisme. C'est c'est
c'est les impacts, les dommages coléfis.
C'est dans le le j'allais dire les mots
qui frappent aujourd'hui le journalisme,
c'est une des dimensions. Je c'est
évidemment que c'est ça révèle que ces
gens sont des inquisiteurs qui eux se
croient tout permis. On est dans le
somum de la tartufie. Mais je pense que
si on veut aujourd'hui convaincre les
gens que le journalisme est un métier à
sauver, euh il faut élargir un peu le
champ. C'est-à-dire que les problèmes
que nous rencontrons, ils sont pas
seulement de cet ordre-là. Évidemment
que c'est pas ces gens-là qui vont nous
aider, hein. Ça c'est très très clair
parce qu'en général en plus ce sont les
mêmes qui évitent qu'on parle de sujets
qui sont des sujet essentiel qui évite
qu'on aille qu'on aille raconter la
réalité du pays, contester un système
économique qui aujourd'hui est en train
de détruire tout le tissu économique et
social des pays occidentaux. Bon, vous
voyez, c'est moi c'est ces sujets-là qui
m'intéressent. Donc euh il me semble que
la question à se poser, c'est est-ce que
le journalisme au sens large aujourd'hui
arrive à raconter ce qui est à l'œuvre,
les mécanismes économiques et politiques
? Est-ce que le journalisme
est un outil démocratique comme il
devrait l'être ou pas ? C'est ça qui
m'intéresse.
Ben là, on est plutôt dans le ou pas ?
Oui, on est plutôt dans le ou pas. On
est plutôt dans le ou pas parce que ce
qui est plus dangereux, me semble-t-il,
c'est que ces gens-là sont aussi des
inquisiteurs idéologiques qui euh en
fait étouffe certains sujets, refusent
une pensée qui n'est pas conforme à leur
dogme. Ça ça me semble gravissime et
simplement je pense que c'est ça s'étend
au-delà de cette fameuse ligue du LOL.
C'est-à-dire que la question de savoir
si les journalistes
sont capables aujourd'hui de ne pas se
comporter en curé ou en inquisiteur,
mais s'ils sont capables de faire
émerger du débat, des arguments, de la
pensée pour permettre aux citoyens de se
faire sa propre opinion. Voilà, ça ça
c'est le vrai sujet. Sommes-nous
aujourd'hui encore un outil
démocratique, c'est-à-dire une le lieu
où le débat va naître pour qu'ensuite
le peuple souverain puisse décider de
son destin ?
La couverture des gilets jaunes par les
médias.
Alors, c'est très intéressant ça. C'est
très intéressant parce que en fait, j'ai
entendu
de la part de gens convaincu de leur
sincérité, convaincu vraiment des des
choses extrêmement diverses.
C'est-à-dire que vous avez des gens qui
vous disent tous les médias au début
étaient favorables au gilets jaunes et
il a fallu un temps fou pour que il se
rende compte qu'il y avait des
problèmes, qu'il y avait de
l'antisémitisme, des trucs comme ça. Or
moi, c'est pas vraiment la perception
que j'ai eu et il m'a semblé qu'on a vu
surgir très très rapidement même avant
même la première manifestation, celle du
17 novembre, l'idée que de toute façon
tout ça a été manipulé par l'extrême
droite à un moment où c'était faux, où
c'était objectivement faux. Il suffisait
justement de se promener sur les sur les
ronds-points
le 17 novembre pour voir qu'il y avait
des gens et c'était ça qui était très
frappant. des gens non politisés surgit
de nulle part de ces endroits de France
que les journalistes ne vont pas voir et
qui tout à coup se faisaient entendre.
Moi, c'est pour ça que j'ai fait cette
une de Marianne qui m'a été reprochée.
Nous sommes le peuple et nous ne nous
terrons plus où nous sommes allés
interroger des gilets jaunes et on a
décidé de de le faire de les interroger,
vous voyez sans filtre, c'est-à-dire un
verbe intime au long cours de ce qu'ils
racontaient de leur vie. C'estàdire pas
seulement leur revendication parce que
ça aussi j'ai vu beaucoup de de médias
qui leur demandaient "Mais alors,
quelles sont vos revendications ? Soyez
plus précis, mais c'est incohérent. Et
alors qu'est-ce que vous proposez pour
changer le système ? Mais c'est pas à
eux de proposer. Ce sont simplement des
gens qui racontaient leur vie, qui
racontaient parfois leur misère, parfois
leurs difficultés, parfois leurs
souffrance et qui tout simplement à un
moment donné se sont dit "Mais attendez,
je suis un citoyen." Citoyen, ça veut
dire que j'ai voix au chapitre. Je dois
pouvoir décider moi aussi de la
politique qui est menée et j'ai choisi
de mettre nous sommes le peuple qui en
effet peut-être réducteur, ils ne sont
pas tout le peuple. Ça ne veut pas dire
que les autres ne sont pas le peuple,
ceux qui sont contre. Ce n'est
absolument pas ça. Mais c'est que tout à
coup, et c'est ça qui m'a frappé,
beaucoup de gens se sont dit "Mais
attendez, mais nous aussi, nous aussi
nous faisons partie de ce peuple et le
peuple est souverain." Et j'ai entendu
ce mot dans la bouche des gilets jaunes
et c'est ça qui m'a intéressé.
C'est-à-dire que après en effet, on va
pas nier que il y a eu ensuite de la
violence, des débordements, qu'il y a eu
petit à petit des gens qui sont qui ont
quitté les ronds-points qui étaient ceux
qui ne pouvaient pas se permettre d'y
rester trop longtemps parce qu'ils
travaillaient, parce qu'ils avaient pas
de quoi rester là. Donc ça a sélectionné
forcément et il y a eu des choses
absolument abjectes. Je dire moi le voir
des quells, des trucs comme ça, ça ne me
plaît pas. euh voir
minoritaire.
Voilà, je continue à penser que c'était
minoritaire et surtout
et je pense que c'est ça qui est très
penser au début le 17 novembre quand ce
mouvement quand ce mouvement surgit et
puis dans les les trois premières
semaines, personne ne peut dire de quel
côté il va basculer. C'est-à-dire
personne ne peut dire potentiellement
c'est fasciste et ça va vers une
insurrection. Ça n'est pas vrai. C'est
une des potentialités. Il se peut en
effet parce que tout mouvement
populaire, tout mouvement euh quasi
insurrectionnel peut basculer dans
quelque chose qui est anti-républicain.
C'est possible. Mais décider dès le
départ que c'était la nature de ce
mouvement,
c'est en quelque sorte une prophétie
autoréalisatrice. C'est-à-dire que quand
on dit ça, on pousse petit à petit ce
mouvement à la radicalité et on le fait
aller vers ce qu'il l'aurait pu ne pas
être.
C'est fait à dessin
à dessin ? Je pense pour certains oui,
c'est-à-dire que je pense que très
clairement au début du mouvement le
pouvoir politique aultique à
grâce à ses connexions dans les médias à
essayer de
C'est pas grâce à ses connexions dans
les médias. C'estàd que je pense que
tout cela hélas se fait de façon
naturelle. J'allais dire il y a pas
besoin que ce soit des gens connectés.
C'est un c'est une pensée qui est
partagée. Qui est partagée pourquoi ?
parce qu'il y a un réflexe de classe.
Moi ce qui m'a frappé, c'est ça, c'est
que tout à coup, on a vu un mouvement
social dans sa sa nature la plus pure.
C'est-à-dire que il n'y avait rien
d'autre que la question sociale qui
surgissait, la question démocratique qui
va avec. Parce qu'en fait, quand vous
avez des inégalités sociales profondes,
et bien la démocratie ne fonctionne
plus. Et quand vous avez des gens qui ne
peuvent pas influer sur les politiques
qui sont menées, la démocratie ne
fonctionne plus. Donc les deux sont
connectés et tout à coup en face, oui,
il y a eu un réflexe de classe. Bien
sûr, on a eu l'impression que tout à
coup les classe dangereuse
ressurgissaient et j'ai été très frappé
de la violence de certains commentaires
dans les médias. C'estàd queil y a quand
même exemple quel médias
par exemple euh
les médias de la Ligue du LOL,
c'est pas ceux-là qui m'ont le plus Non
non, c'est pas enfin je sais je vais
vous dire je ne sais même pas exactement
euh enfin j'ai pas je ne connais pas
tous les membres de la Ligue du LOL he
donc voilà. Oui, j'ai en tête les unibés
mais c'est mais c'est pas là. Oui, mais
c'est alors je suis désolé, c'est pas là
qu'il y a eu les textes les plus
virulents euh contre les gilets jaunes.
Et puis surtout euh
surtout je pense que c'est dans
l'expression de certains journalistes ou
certains philosophes médiatiques sur les
réseaux sociaux que la violence était
très frappante. C'est-à-dire quand on
voit des termes comme beau, comme
je sais plus, j'ai même plus en tête.
Alors oui, Jojo ça c'est la dernière en
date, c'est finalement presque plus soft
par rapport à tout ce qui s'est fait.
Enfin, quand on quand on voit des des
journalistes euh expliquer sur les
réseaux sociaux que il va peut-être
falloir mettre en place l'article 16 de
la Constitution, c'est-à-dire les pleins
pouvoirs au président de la République,
euh là demande où on habite, quoi. Et
donc je mais c'est c'est ça qui a été
très intéressant dans ce mouvement,
c'est que tout à coup on a eu
l'impression qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui tremblait, que ce pouvoir au sens
large he quand je dise pouvoir c'est pas
seulement le gouvernement mais ce
pouvoir a eu peur et on le voit dans la
semaine du 1er au 8 décembre, il y a eu
une véritable peur et c'est là qu'on
voit les délires les plus les plus
grands.
C'est pour ça qu'on a vu des blindés
avec du gaz du gaz CS enrichiou voilà
que vous avez sorti d'ailleurs.
Mais oui oui oui. a sorti à Marianne
bien sûr parce que euh justement c'est
on voit là des excès qui sont comment
dire qui sont la conséquence directe du
refus de poser de d'apporter une réponse
politique. C'est-à-dire que il aurait
suffi de répondre dès le départ
politiquement à ce qui se jouait là,
c'est-à-dire cette demande de démocratie
et de justice sociale.
Macron, il a pas de légitimité.
Alors cette question, elle est très
intéressante aussi, cette question de la
légitimité parce que elle fait débat et
que on sent bien que là aussi elle
crispe terriblement.
C'est pour ça nous on a à Marian, on a
fait la semaine dernière un
article spécifiquement sur cette
questionlà, l'égalité, légitimité à
partir d'un sondage sur ce que donnerait
aujourd'hui une présidentielle et
surtout sur le rôle du vote blanc. Or,
c'est très intéressant là de nos jours
là maintenant en cas de second tour
Marine Le Pen, Emmanuel Macron, il y
aurait quand même 19 % de vote blanc,
c'estàd quasiment le double de ce qu'il
y a eu en 2017. Donc ça veut dire qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens qui estiment qu'ils
ont pas envie d'être réduit à un choix
qu'ils estiment biaisé.
Pour cautionner ce système.
Mais c'est ça, c'est exactement ça.
Alors, simplement la question de la de
la légitimité.
On a publié une interview d'un d'un
sociologue spécialiste du vote blanc et
cetera, Jérémy Moile et qui a cette
distinction que je trouve assez
intéressante, c'est en fait Macron a été
légalement et légitimement élu. Il est
légitime en tant que président, en tant
qu'homme bien sûr, puisque
il a été élu dans les règles de la 5e
République. Alors après moi je conteste
la ce qu'on a fait de la 5e République
mais ça c'est autre chose. Mais en tout
cas ça a respecté la légalité et donc il
est légitimement président de la
République. Est-ce que pour autant son
programme politique est légitime ? Non.
Parce que les gens qui ont voté pour lui
n'ont pas voté pour son programme, ils
ont voté pour ce qui l'incarnait à ce
moment-là. C'est-à-dire d'abord le fait
de ne pas avoir Marine Le Pen au
pouvoir, enfin différentes autres
données. Et peut-être que la prise en
compte du vote blanc permettrait de
faire prendre conscience de cela.
C'est-à-dire que ça empêcherait qu'un
président puisse être élu et dire
"Puisque vous m'avez élu, c'est que vous
c'est que vous m'avez donné un blanc
sein. Donc j'applique mon programme à la
lettre et j'irai jusqu'au bout."
Regardez par exemple quand Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2008
fait voter le traité de Lisbone qui est
donc on est bien d'accord le copiercollé
du traité constitutionnel de 2005 qui a
été refusé par 55 % des Français.
Il explique après "Ah bah oui, mais
j'avais toute légitimité à faire ça
puisque c'était écrit dans mon
programme. Les gens ont voté pour mon
programme donc ils ont ils sont
d'accord. Mais enfin c'est d'une
hypocrisie totale. Tout le monde sait
très bien que les gens qui ont élu
Sarkozy en 2007 ne l'ont pas élu pour
cette question là. Faut faut vraiment se
[__] de la gueule du monde pour
prétendre ça. Ils ont voté pour d'autres
raisons, pour d'autres choses, qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas, mais certainement
pas pour refaire passer le traité de
Lisbonne. Donc expliquer que parce qu'on
a été élu, on a un blancin pour
appliquer l'ensemble de son programme me
semble extrêmement dangereux dans un
moment politique comme celui que nous
vivons aujourd'hui où il y a justement
un éclatement des opinions où on voit
très bien que des fractures se creusent
entre différentes catégories de la
population et que il devient de plus en
plus compliqué de rassembler les
Français. L'idée de cette élection du
président de la République au suffrage
universel, c'était cette idée que à la
fin un homme, une personnalité
justement serait légitime aux yeux de
tous les Français, même ceux qui
n'avaient pas voté pour lui. Ça ça ne
marche plus.
La guerre civile, c'est pour quand ?
Moi, je me bats justement pour éviter
toute violence, pour éviter toute guerre
civile. C'est pour ça que j'ai écrit
pendant cette crise des gilets jaunes un
édito qui s'intitulait pour une
révolution raisonnable. C'est-à-dire que
alors certains m'ont dit "Mais ça
n'existe pas, c'est un oxyor." Oui, mais
c'est ça qui est intéressant.
C'està-dire que je pense qu'il faut
absolument une révolution dans le sens
où il faut bouleverser ce système qui
est en train de nous faire crever, qui
est en train de détruire tout le tissu
social et économique du pays. Pas
seulement de la France d'ailleurs, mais
on voit petit à petit des territoires
qui se désertifient. C'estàd que la
richesse est absorbée dans les
métropoles et ce système économique
favorise ceux qui sont déjà inclus.
C'est le le le gagnant qui remporte la
mise et petit à petit bah on voit des
villages totalement vides. Les services
publics qui s'en vont parce que
forcément comme l'argent ne rentre plus
dans les caisses de l'État puisque les
multinationales ne payent pas assez
d'impôts, et bien on a plus de quoi
entretenir des services publics. On a
plus le droit on a plus de quoi
rééquilibrer entre les territoires.
C'est tout cela. C'est toute cette
logique là qui est en train de nous
tuer. C'est le fait que petit à petit
toutes les petites PME ont été tuées par
une concurrence déloyale totale et que
du coup vous avez plus de bassin de
bassin économique dans des tas de
petites villes. Vous vous baladez à
Isouin, vous vous baladez à Moulin.
C'est absolument tragique. Bon donc tout
ça doit être doit faire l'objet d'une
révolution absolue. Sauf que cette
révolution je la veux démocratique, je
la veux républicaine, donc je la veux
raisonnable. fondé sur la raison,
c'est-à-dire sur un système qui puisse
rassembler l'ensemble des gens qui
aujourd'hui veulent se mettre ensemble
pour que ce pays vive mieux.
Euh Macron chez Hanouna,
Chiapas, Hanouna.
Oui, Marlè Chiappa chez Anouna. Pas
encore Emmanuel Macron.
Ça viendra peut-être. Écoutez,
c'est la la politique des nouilles dans
slip, c'est c'est quoi ?
Oui, on va dire c'est ça nous raconte ce
qui est en train de devenir le système
politico-médiatique
façon de love story.
Voilà, c'estàd que l'argument pour moi
est particulièrement dangereux.
C'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit de dire on va
aller chercher les gens là où ils sont
et puisque Anouna fait de l'audience,
ben ça veut dire que les gens sont chez
Anouna. Donc on va aller leur parler là.
D'abord, Anouna fait pas une audience
telle qu'on puisse considérer que c'est
là que sont les gens, les Français, les
citoyens, mais surtout
c'est considérer que le citoyen
n'est pas à un moment donné capable de
faire la différence entre le moment où
il rentre du boulot, il a envie oui
parfois de s'abrutir devant des
stupidités à la télé et donc il allume
sa télé et il regarde la téléréalité à
Nouna, que sais-je ? Et puis des moments
où il a une conscience qu'il exerce, un
esprit critique et où il a envie de
penser. Là aussi, cette crise des gilets
jaunes, elle est assez fabuleuse pour
une chose, c'est qu'on a vu des gens
tout à coup qui depuis longtemps ne
parlaient plus politique, même ne
lisaient plus forcément le journaux et
qui tout à coup ont eu envie de
s'informer, de lire, de débattre, de
discuter. C'est-à-dire que ce qui
existait dans les bistros à la fin du
19e siècle, parce que c'était ça,
c'était des lieux de débat, c'était des
lieux d'exercice de la démocratie, tout
à coup ressurgi sur des ronds-points
parce que le drame aujourd'hui, c'est la
destruction des lieux de sociabilité,
c'est-à-dire de ces endroits où se
construit la démocratie par échange, par
discussion, par argumentation.
Quand vous avez des villes, des villages
qui se vident de leur bistro, de leur
petit commerce, vous n'avez plus ces
lieux où les gens se croisent, où ils
discutent. Je à la fin du 19e siècle,
vous aviez des lectures publiques de
journaux dans les dans les bistro et on
échangeait ensuite là-dessus. Toute
cette culture populaire est en train
d'être asséchée. C'est pas en allant
chez Hanouna qu'on va la qu'on va la
faire revivre. Ça c'est une escroquerie.
Ça transforme la politique en spectacle
et ça prend les gens pour des imbéciles.
Ils ont le droit de regarder à Nouna
pour se détendre mais ils sont
parfaitement capables à côté de débattre
ensemble. Il faut simplement pas les
prendre pour des cons.
Une chapass chapasse comment
ch euh c'est pas les dire chiapas. Non
le quand il va chez Hanouna alors que
Hanouna a eu des plaintes par le CSA
pour des raisons bien précises.
C'est quoi ? C'est une façon de
d'adouber Anouna ? C'est une façon de
Ah ben c'est en tout cas de
l'indignation à géométrie variable hein.
C'estàd que Marlè Chiappa est quand même
la première à se récrier dès qu'il y a
ce qu'on appelle maintenant des
dérapages. Et là tout à coup ça dérange
plus quand il s'agit d'aller faire
passer la la bonne parole politique.
Donc en effet je pense que ça pose un
sérieux problème de crédibilité.
On revient on fait une petite parenthèse
gentille. Laaffaire Benala
parenthèse gentille.
Ah non c'est gentil.
Non c'est surtout c'est surtout
concernant là. Stom non ou
moi je préfère Alstom. On commence par
je trouve qu'alstom c'est beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus essentiel comme
enjeu que Benala. Benala c'est
révélateur, c'est-à-dire que
c'est la ligue du lol macronesque.
Ça nous raconte surtout
le
le disons ce qu'il y a d'inquiétant à
savoir cette façon de s'entourer de la
part du président de la République.
s'entourer de ce genre de personnage,
c'est à un moment donné
estimer que on est finalement un peu à
côté, que l'on n pas forcément à se
plier aux mêmes règles que le reste de
la population.
Voilà, je pense qu'il y a là un comment
dire ce que un ancien ministre de
l'intérieur, Gérard Colomb a appelé de
l'UBrice, c'estàdire de l'orgueil. Je
crois qu'il y a véritablement ça et que
c'est inquiétant. Pourquoi ? parce que
ça nous raconte le rapport d'Emmanuel
Macron à la démocratie.
Une petite perquisition chez Mia Part.
Oui, bien sûr. Non, mais tout tout est
délirant dans cette affaire. Absolument
tout. la perquisition chez Médiia part,
le ce qu'on découvre de l'espèce de
sentiment d'impunité des uns et des
autres, euh tout le toute la façon dont
euh finalement des gens qui ne devraient
jamais mettre les pieds dans les palais
de la République
gravitent dans ce monde-là puis dans des
mondes interlopes. Évidemment qu'il y a
toujours eu des gens douteux
à l'Élysée.
Je dire enfin la France-afrique sous de
Gaulle, c'était pas particulièrement
reluisant car
voilà Focar n'était pas un type
forcément d'une honnêteté d'une grandeur
d'âme fabuleuse. Pour autant tout cela
ne s'étalait pas. À partir du moment
déjà où on voit un Nicolas SarkoZi euh
entretenir des liens avec un Alexandre
de Jouri, on passe dans une autre
dimension.
Et puis là maintenant, on a donc Benala.
Je pense que tout cela en effet nous
raconte une dérive petit à petit d'un
pouvoir qui ne
se vit plus comme au service du peuple.
Le mot ministre, il veut dire ça. Il
veut dire serviteur. C'est-à-dire que
les élus sont des serviteurs du peuple
et ils sont là pour appliquer la
politique que veut le peuple. On n
absolument plus là-dedans et je pense
que ça a des répercussions aussi sur les
choix politiques que font ces gens-là.
C'està-dire que ce qui ce qui est un
révélateur de leur psychologie explique
aussi leur façon de d'opérer des choix
politiques.
On fait un petit pointiller sur Alstom.
Alst,
c'est beau, c'est mené d'une main de
maître. Non mais Alstom est le cas
d'école du scandale absolu
que le monde médiatique n'a pas voulu
voir. Et moi, c'est ça qui me frappe.
C'est le temps qu'il a fallu pour que
des journalistes s'intéressent à ça.
Moi, je veux dire, j'ai été alerté
là-dessus euh par mon co-auteur
Jean-Michel 4 points avec qui euh on a
fondé le comité Orwell parce que euh lui
s'est intéressé à cela parce que c'est
un journaliste qui fait son travail de
journaliste économique, c'est-à-dire
qu'il enquête sur les tout ce qui est en
train de détruire tous les fleurons
industriels français. Voilà. Et donc il
avait publié un livre Alstom scandale
d'État où il racontait tout ça. Mais ça
n'intéressait personne, strictement
personne. C'estàd la façon dont le les
États-Unis ont fait pression en
appliquant l'extraterritorialité de
leurs droits en prenant en otage quand
même. Pierucci, il a été pris en otage,
ça s'appelle comme ça
le cadre de Halstom qui a été séquestré
qui a fait de la tôle aux États-Unis
parce qu'il s'agissait de faire pression
sur Patrick Cron pour qu'il vende Alstom
à Général Electric ce qu'il a fait sans
informer suffisamment l'État français de
ce qui était en train de se passer parce
que
disons que l'idée était de mettre l'État
français devant le fait accompli. Et
ensuite, le problème c'est le pouvoir
politique français qui ne réagit pas,
qui ne défend pas euh les intérêts de de
la France et qui laisse partir quand
même ce qui relève de la souveraineté du
pays. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui,
les turbines de nos sous-marins
nucléaires, elles sont détenues par les
Américains. C'est hallucinant. C'estàd
qu'aujourd'hui, s'il y a 2003 la guerre
en Irak, on peut plus dire non parce que
si on dit qu'on veut pas y aller, bah on
a plus de sous-marin nucléaire. Alors,
vous savez qu'il y a et ça aussi je suis
effaré, euh nous avons annoncé dans
Marian, on a interviewé Pierouci avec
Jean-Michel 4 points et ils ont expliqué
qu'il y a aujourd'hui un tour de table
qui essaie de se monter pour racheter
les turbines
nucléaires à Général Electric, ce qui en
fait est en difficulté et donc pourrait
les revendre. Il faut absolument que la
France récupère cela qui est en plus
c'est en plus euh une des
une des boîtes qui a des qui a des
contrat. Donc c'est c'est profitable et
surtout c'est un enjeu de souveraineté
majeur. Là
là on vient
zéro reprise. Là aussi ça n'intéresse
personne. Alors qu'il faudrait
évidemment faire en sorte que l'État
français appuie ce tour de table pour
que nous puissions récupérer ce qui
relève de notre souveraineté.
Là là il y a 50 sous-marins qui
hypothétiquement vont être vendus à
l'Australie. Ça a été fait à votre avis
par la avec la Val des États-Unis ?
C'est toujours fait avec la Valle des
États-Unis. On n' pas le droit de vendre
des armes sans l'aval des États-Unis.
Pourquoi ? Parce que une fois de plus,
extraterritorialité du droit, pression
de l'impérialisme américain.
C'est-à-dire que s'il y a le moindre
mais le moindre composant
même le micropuce électronique fabriqué
aux États-Unis dans un de nos armements,
il faut demander l'autorisation des
États-Unis. Et nous le faisons bien sûr,
nous le faisons. D'autant que les
transactions sont le plus souvent en
dollar puisque nous avons fait en sorte
que l'euro ne soit pas une monnaie
concurrente du dollar.
Donc tout fait en dollar dépend des
États-Unis peut faire l'objet d'amende
absolument pharamineuse, peut nous
déstabiliser. Donc on se couche. Tout
cela devrait être raconté en permanence
dans les médias parce que ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui, c'estàdire ce qui
change la vie quotidienne des gens,
c'est lié à ça. C'estd que la
destruction, la désindustrialisation de
la France, les millions enfin le million
d'emplois industriels disparus dans les
15 dernières années, c'est aussi la
conséquence de ce genre de chos. Donc il
faut le raconter. Ça a une influence sur
la vie des gens. Alors évidemment, si on
leur raconte pas, ils peuvent pas savoir
comment ça se passe exactement. Ils
peuvent pas savoir que il y aurait moyen
de faire autrement. Là par exemple,
ils ont peut-être pas envie.
Les citoyens si ils ont envie, ils ont
envie.
Qu'est-ce qui vous Qu'est-ce qui vous
fait dire ça ?
Parce que euh j'ai confiance en
l'appétit de savoir des gens et que je
pense que c'est simplement qu'on ne leur
donne pas. Regardez, je vais un exemple
qui n'a rien à voir. Mais euh quand il y
a eu une guerre farouche menée par les
industriels du lait pour jeter l'eau
probre sur le lait cru parce que c'est
compliqué, ça coûte plus cher et cetera.
Bon, ils ont voulu demander à ce que le
camemberbermandie soit plus forcément au
lescru. C'est une AOP. La pression était
telle, il représentait 80 % du marché.
La pression était telle que l'État
français était sur le point de reculer.
On a fait un documentaire. En
l'occurrence Périco Legas, mon mari a
fait un documentaire qui s'appelait ces
fromages qu'on assassine. C'était en
2007 qui racontait tout ça, toute cette
pression. Et ben, ça a marché. C'est que
le documentaire a eu du succès,
l'information des consommateurs a porté,
c'est-à-dire que les fromages
industriels ont perdu des parts de
marché et les véritables camemberber au
les crues ont gagné des parts de marché.
Ce qui prouve que quand on informe le
consommateur qui est un citoyen, il peut
choisir ensuite. Ça veut dire que par
exemple là, quand vous avez des
scandales sur la viande avariée
polonaise, pourquoi l'Union européenne
depuis des années refuse-telle la
traçabilité de la viande dans les plats
préparés ?
Évidemment, c'est une question d'argent
parce que si on si on informe le
consommateur, bah il y a des trucs dont
il voudra pas forcément parce qu'il a
pas confiance
qui pourra plus payer.
C'est pas qu'il pourra plus les payer,
c'est que il choisira le consommateur
informé, ensuite il fait ses arbitrages.
Tout le monde peut pas se payer des
produits de qualité, c'est sûr. Mais on
peut décider que sur certains domaines,
on va réussir à se payer des choses de
qualité. Quit à limiter d'autres achats.
On fait des arbitrages mais au moins on
les fait soi-même. On est libre parce
qu'on est informé. Le rôle des médias
c'est d'assurer l'information pour que
le citoyen soit émancipé par ce savoir
et cette information. Qu'il puisse
opérer ses choix lui-même. Il s'agit pas
de dire aux gens ce qu'ils doivent faire
parce que ça c'est le bien et ça c'est
le mal. Pour faire son choix en âme et
conscience, il faut des journalistes
pour ça.
Mais oui, ça coûte cher et
et ça coûte cher et et ils arrivent plus
à se financer et et c'est c'est c'est la
pagaille. Ils sont rachetés par beaucoup
de milliardaires.
Ça devient un petit peu la radio
chinoise. Non.
Alors, il faut pas non plus caricaturer.
Caricaturer, votez tous Macron. Ils ont
fait tous leur une à voter Macron. Non,
on est d'accord, on est d'accord. Il y a
eu
a fait ça non ? Non
non
non. Marianne enfin de toute façon je
moi j'y étais pas hein en tout cas et je
pense que Marianne est un journal qui
est en train de enfin c'est c'est mon
rôle et c'est ma mission de retrouver ce
qui a fait sa vocation de départ.
C'est-à-dire surtout
de s'affranchir du prête à penser,
d'être contre ce que Jean-François Can
appelait la pensée unique. Voilà,
c'était ça. C'est je crois que c'est
lui-même qui a inventé l'expression
pensée unique. Et voilà, l'idée c'était
de sortir de cela. Bon donc simplement
le le on va pas expliquer que parce que
tous les médias appartiennent à des
milliardaires, tous les journalistes
sont vendus. C'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça. C'est-à-dire que
d'abord il y a une différence entre le
travail du journaliste de terrain et le
rôle ensuite du patron de presse et le
rôle des éditorialistes. Il y a une
différence. Et ensuite les actionnaires
ne comment dire n'interviennent pas
forcément directement dans la rédaction.
Ça dépend sur quel sujet. Bien sûr.
Après, la pression de la régie
publicitaire est parfois beaucoup plus
importante que celle des actionnaires.
En général dans la presse, c'est ça qui
pose problème, c'est la question
publicitaire. Je parlais tout à l'heure
de notre sur la fondation Louis Vuitton.
LVMH est l'un des principaux euh comment
dire ? C'est l'un des principaux clients
de publicité pour les pour les journaux.
C'est compliqué. Je crois savoir que
quand Libération avait fait sa une sur
Bernard Arnaud, Castoir Richcon, ça
avait été compliqué derrière. Donc ça
c'est une question aussi essentielle.
Mais là, on est face à un problème. Le
les médias ont
c'est la laisse qui se tend sur le
collier des journalistes.
Oui, mais bien sûr. Mais bien sûr. Mais
il faut se demander pourquoi. Il y a
toujours eu ces problèmes là dans la
presse. Depuis qu'elle existe, il y a
des pressions. Depuis qu'elle existe, il
y a la question de savoir à qui
appartiennent les journaux et de qui ils
dépendent de leur lien avec la bourse.
Vous pouvez lire toute l'histoire de la
presse. Vous trouverez toujours des
débats là-dessus. Simplement ce qui a
changé, c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
milliardaires qui possèdent la presse ne
sont plus des patrons de presse, ce sont
plus des gens dont c'est le métier. Ce
sont souvent des industriels qui souvent
s'achètent de l'influence à travers ça.
Ça veut pas dire qu'il dictent les
articles, mais ça veut dire quand même
qu'il possèdent quelque chose qui va
leur permettre ensuite éventuellement de
compter dans le paysage. Mais surtout le
problème c'est que les journaux
n'arrivent plus à vivre de leur lecteur.
C'està-dire que les gens lisent de moins
en moins. Alors on peut se demander
pourquoi et les médias ont peut-être
aussi fait en sorte qu'on ne les lise
plus. Mais en tout cas les journaux
vivent de moins en moins de leur lecteur
et ils sont donc de plus en plus
dépendants de la publicité. Sachant que
la publicité de toute façon ne leur
rapporte plus rien non plus. Pourquoi ?
parce que les annonceurs préfèrent aller
sur internet où là toute la man est
captée par Facebook et Google. Donc on
est face aujourd'hui à un risque de
disparition du journalisme tel qu'il
devrait exister, c'est-à-dire un
journalisme qui soit un journalisme
d'enquête, de reportage qui est sur le
terrain, qui puisse rapporter une
information la plus honnête possible qui
permett aux lecteurs de découvrir des
choses qu'il ne connaissait pas et
surtout des choses qu'il n'auraient
peut-être pas eu envie de connaître
parce que c'est aussi ça le rôle d'un
journal.
Vous avez écouté les les déclarations de
Macron concernant la presse ? Euh oui
oui.
Ça ressemble à quoi ?
Ça ressemble à une vie
discours de Kimjumun.
N'exagérons rien. Je j'essaie de
toujours rester nuancé. Donc euh non,
c'est une vision euh qui est finalement
aujourd'hui extrêmement répandue euh et
qui relève
de ce que j'appellerais, mais il est pas
Macron n'est pas du tout le seul
responsable, un environnement de soft
totalitarisme.
C'est-à-dire que
il s'agit pas de faire pression par la
force sur les gens, il s'agit de faire
adhérer à un système parce qu'il est
considéré comme le bien, parce qu'il est
considéré comme tout ce qui nous
préserve du mal. Le mal c'est au choix
le populisme, le fascisme, les extrêmes,
voilà. Et comme alors c'est très
intéressant ce terme, le souverainisme.
C'est-à-dire que là, ça y est, le mot
souverainisme est devenu synonyme
d'extrême droite, ce qui est quand même
assez dingue.
Souverainiste, complotiste, en fait.
Oui, aussi on ça ça va avec complotiste.
Euh c'est-à-dire que
la les dernières par exemple les les
travaux de Conspiracy Watch et de la
Fondation Jean Jorè sur le complotisme
sont d'ailleurs assez délicieux de ce
point de vue là. C'estàdire que
dans quel sens délicieux ? Genre ? Ah
bah dans le sens où finalement tout le
monde est complotiste. Il s'agit de nous
démontrer que tout le monde est
complotiste et que euh comment dire on
peut capter de l'argent public pour
faire des petites choses après derrière
parce que comme il y a beaucoup de
complotistes, on on se on devient
nécessaire à combattre le complotisme.
C'est ça.
Bien sûr, puisqu'on est on est la vigie
face à ce danger immédiat. Mais encore
une fois, il s'agit là de mots qu'on
accolle mais qui ne sont jamais définis.
Or, moi, j'estime qu'il faut définir par
exemple le mot souverainisme, que ce
soit un bon mot ou un mauvais mot,
c'est-à-dire les gens justement ne
comprennent plus ce que ça veut dire.
Alors, disons-le clairement, défendre la
souveraineté, c'est-à-dire ce qu'on a vu
dans euh le l'émergence des gilets
jaunes. Défendre la souveraineté,
c'està-dire la la capacité du peuple à
décider de son destin. C'est la
définition de la démocratie. Donc en
fait
normalement n'importe quel véritable
démocrate devrait être souverainiste.
Après, il y a différentes manières,
différentes types de politiques qu'on
peut défendre mais en tout cas défendre
la souveraineté du peuple, ça me semble
fondamental, ça me semble la base. Donc
à coller ça à un discours extrémiste,
c'est particulièrement inquiétant. C'est
une façon d'expliquer que la
souveraineté du peuple, la démocratie
est finalement à ses accessoires par
rapport à la préservation d'un système
économique qui aujourd'hui s'impose à
tous. Je je vais vous lire euh un petit
extrait de de Marianne.
Je m'en doutais un peu.
Ah bah t'inquiète, on t'a pas fait venir
B rien.
Alors juste un extrait euh euh sur
Sinkerview sur nous. Euh cette chaîne
YouTube compte près de 270000 abonnés et
publie plusieurs dizaines d'interviews
avec des personnalités très diverses
idéologiquement mais portant général
généralement un discours en rupture avec
le système. Bon,
jusque là, c'est très bien. Le toné
le ton des questions sans concession est
très porté sur le dévoilement prétendu
de machination de puissant de ce monde.
Refaites bien ce que les internautes
viennent chercher sur le web. On y parle
de politique hors sentier battu. Quit à
ce que les questions fassent la parbelle
à une vision complotiste.
Raconte un peu à papa.
Allez,
le journaliste qui a écrit cela,
est-ce qu'il a publié en le faisant
relire son article ?
Il a fait relire au rédacteur en chef du
site
qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle vous pouvez le voir sur
l'ours de Marianne mais pourquoi il faut
il s'appelle Thomas Vampouille et c'est
voilà je mais on va pas enfin je il ne
s'agit pas de désigner des gens il a
fait son travail ce journaliste après
c'est sa vision c'est sa vision on voit
qu'il raconte ce qu'estw et qu'après il
estime que dans le ton des questions Il
y a parfois une même souvent dit-il une
façon de les tourner qui donne
l'impression que cela révélerait des
choses cachées au grand public.
Quand on demande à Jean-Michel Apatti ou
à à à aux journalistes du monde ou à à
comment il s'appelle tout petit là
Pujadas
euh sur le dîner du siècle et la
collision entre journaliste et puissant.
C'est révéler des choses comme ça ? Ah
non, mais encore une fois, moi ça ne me
gêne absolument pas qu'on pose ce genre
de question et c'est quand même la
troisème fois que je suis interviewée
sur Syerview. Si je considérais que
c'est une chaîne complotiste, je ne
viendrai pas, on est d'accord. Après,
chacun a l'appréciation qu'il veut sur
le ton qui est employé, la façon de
faire du journalisme. Et je n'ai pas à
réécrire un journaliste. S'il a écrit
ça, je peux en discuter avec lui et lui
dire "Je suis pas d'accord, mais je ne
vais pas le réécrire." Voilà, c'est
toute la différence. Il est libre
d'écrire ce qu'il veut.
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir un droit de
réponse ? Non, Marianne ?
Bah oui. Bah bien sûr. Bien sûr. Il y a
des règles pour le droit de réponse.
Alors, c'est des règles juridiques
extrêmement complexes et cetera. Enfin,
de toute façon, vous pouvez avocat.
Oui. Oui. Bon, j'imagine. Mais de toute
façon, bien sûr. Et et encore une fois,
je suis ici parce que pour ma part,
j'estime que vous faites un travail qui
est un travail passionnant. Voilà. Donc,
si vous voulez que Marianne vous donne
la parole, on vous donne la parole. On
fait naître un débat. Au contraire, moi
je suis pour ce genre de débat et ce
genre de discussion. Et encore une fois,
moi je j'emploie ce mot complotisme avec
beaucoup de comment dire de de prudence
parce que pour l'instant je trouve qu'on
a des élites qui elles sont de plus en
plus complotistes et qui voient des
complots partout et qui voient des
complotistes partout les deux à la fois.
Quand quand les hackers étaient accusés
de complotisme parce que ils disaient
qu'on était surveillé, parce queon
disait qu'on était euh fliqué, que euh
l'État se gavait, que il y avait des
écoutes un petit peu sauvages euh et que
derrière ils ont passé des lois pour euh
régulariser les choses, nous traiter de
complotiste. C'est-à-dire que des fois,
il y a c'est une façon de jeter l'eau
propre sur quelqu'un pour le faire
terre. C'est c'est quoi ?
Il y a un mélange de différentes choses,
je pense. C'est-à-dire que il s'agit
parfois de faire terire les gens et il
s'agit parfois de de certitude
de la part de gens qui sont parfaitement
sincèrement convaincus qu'ils sont dans
le vrai. Et ceux-là sont, j'allais dire
bien plus dangereux que ceux qui veulent
faire terre. Le c'est d'ailleurs le cas
dans beaucoup de domainesme.
L'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions.
Le drame c'est que la plupart des gens
sont très sincèrement persuadés qu'ils
sont des instruments du bien contre le
mal et qu'il s'agit d'extirper le mal
partout où il est.
C'est pas le rôle du journalisme.
Bah non, c'est pas le rôle du
journaliste. Encore une fois, le
journaliste, c'est pas un curé. Voilà.
Donc le journaliste, il est là pour
mettre en avant les différents
arguments, pour replacer les faits dans
un contexte, pour permettre aux citoyens
de décrypter, de comprendre ce contexte,
de comprendre la mécanique qui aboutit à
telle ou telle décision, à tel ou tel
phénomène. C'est tout cela le rôle d'un
journaliste. aussi de faire vivre le
pluralisme parce qu'il y a aussi un
problème énorme qu'on a aujourd'hui qui
est l'espèce de renforcement des
certitude chez beaucoup beaucoup de de
citoyens. C'est qu'il y a il y a une
radicalisation de chaque groupe social
sur ses propres certitudes. Le rôle d'un
journal c'est normalement de sortir les
gens de leur certitude. C'est-à-dire
qu'en gros Charles Peggy disait il faut
qu'une
il faut qu'une revue mécontente un 5è de
son lectorat. mais jamais le même 5e.
Donc en gros, on raconte aux gens ce
qu'il ce qu'ils n'ont peut-être pas vu,
ce qu'ils n'ont peut-être pas perçu ou
ce qu'ils voyaient mais qu'ils
n'arrivaient pas à nommer et puis de
temps en temps, on leur montre ce qu'ils
ne voulaient pas voir. Voilà, on les
bouscule. Le problème, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, sans doute habitué aussi
par le principe des algorithmes et par
le mode de fonctionnement totalement
fermé des réseaux sociaux, beaucoup de
gens refusent cette petite part de
remise en question. Ils attendent qu'on
les conforte en permanence dans leur
certitude. Et c'est vrai pour tout le
monde hein, c'est pas seulement certains
types, c'est dans chaque chaque
représentant d'une opinion ou qu'elle se
situe sur les chiquers politiques ou
idéologiques a cette tendance là qui
doit être combattue en permanence. Mais
c'est devenu de plus en plus difficile
parce queon a beaucoup de gens qui
trouvent insupportable la moindre remise
en question de leur certitude.
On va passer aux questions d'internet
euh parce que je sais que vous avez un
emploi du ton très chargé.
Euh euh
j'ai un journal à faire
à faire tourner
mais c'est pas évident du tout.
Ouais ouais. Alors euh ça c'est bon.
Traitement des t des violences
policières dans les médias. Un mot
rapide dessus. Est-ce que le LBD on
commence à se réveiller quand il y a les
Canadiens, les Suisses qui volent au
secours de la population française pour
dire voilà quand même c'est compliqué.
Il a fallu du temps. Il y a eu des
articles qui ont été faits, il y a eu
des enquêtes. Bon, on a vu du FR qui
faisait ce travail là. Nous à Mariane,
on a publié une grosse enquête sur le
site de Marianne d'un
Il y a il y a un pool d'investigation
chez Marianne ?
Oui, il y a un pool d'investigation chez
Marianne.
Combien de personnes ?
Il est pas énorme. On est on est une
équipe minuscule. Donc on a on a trois
investigateurs si on compte. Mais après
tous les autres, ils sont investigateurs
aussi he ils sont journalistes. Mais
disons qu'on en a trois qui sont
spécialisés. On en a un dans
l'investigation économique, Emmanuel
Lévi qui nous a sorti justement les
rapports de la Cour des comptes qui nous
qui travaill beaucoup sur les
autoroutes, sur les régies d'eau ou les
choses comme ça. Vous voyez, ça ce sont
des sujets queon met en avant assez
souvent. Voilà. Et puis on a des
investigateurs qui vont faire fouiller
un peu partout.
Quelle était la question ? La question
était les violences policières et donc
on a publié évidemment des articles, on
a publié aussi des éditoriaux, on a
traité cette questionlà.
Et les autres ? Bah les autres, je pense
que ça dépend en fonction de leur
sensibilité justement et que c'est ça
qui est euh disons que il a été il est
devenu impossible dans ce dans cette
crise de tenir les debouts. Ce que nous
on essaie de faire à Marianne,
c'est-à-dire euh de ne de n'avoir aucune
complaisance pour des gens qui viennent
pour casser, pour des gens qui viennent
pour frapper du flic. Moi, le slogan
Tout le monde déteste la police, je le
trouve absolument ignoble.
C'est délirant comme slogan, mais en
face, on peut aussi dénoncer des
violences policières qui sont dues aussi
à l'absence de formation, au mauvais
usage de ces de ces armes et au fait que
évidemment elles sont dangereuses.
OK. Alors l'absence de formation, je
veux bien, ils doivent tirer trois ou
cinq cartouches de LBD, d'accord. Mais
quand on entend
grâce à des des reporteurs de terrain
pour la plupart venant d'Internet, on
pense d'ailleurs à ta miss et des choses
comme ça. Quand on entend des des flics
dire à voter quand il tirent pleine
tête, c'est
ou des choses comme ça il faut des
sanctions.
Des journalistes isolés à trois sur un
pont se prendre deux grenades de
désencerclement au pied.
L'IGPN
le problème. Le problème c'est qu'il n'y
a pas assez de sanctions. c'est que
alors encore une fois, on est face à des
êtres humains. Il y a peut-être des mecs
qui craquent, il y a peut-être des
policiers aussi qui n'en peuvent plus,
mais c'est inacceptable. Ou le
recrutement, c'est ce que je dis, le
recrutement, la formation, c'est aussi
attendez ce qu'on a montré dans le
dans les enquêes
respect qu'on peut avoir sur le CAP.
Bah bien sûr, il y a des CAP qui sont
c'est une formation qui qui a longtemps
été de qualité.
Après, on pourrait parler aussi de
l'évolution, de l'enseignement dans les
filières courtes et cetera. Ce serait
tout un sujet, il nous faudrait 3 he
mais on a montré nous dans nos enquêtes
que le problème c'est aussi d'avoir
utilisé pour le maintien de l'ordre des
policiers qui n'étaient pas qui
n'étaient pas formés pour ça parce que
c'était pas leur véritable domaine de
compétence. Mais c'est ça, c'estd que
quand vous mettez des mecs comme ça et
que vous leur dites "Bon, vous allez
avec un LDB, vous avez quelques heures
de formation, enfin c'est aberrant,
c'est ça qui est profondément dangereux.
Mais il faut évidemment raconter comment
ça s'est fait, que en plus on s'est
retrouvé avec une espèce de guerre des
polices, avec le des unités différentes
qui maintenaient l'ordre de deux façons
différentes sur la même place. Enfin,
des trucs, ça a été un grand n'importe
quoi quand même le maintien de l'ordre.
Vous êtes intéressé au recrutement dans
les écoles de police ?
J'ai pas fait d'enquête récemment, mais
je pense en effet que votre attention
dessus parce que c'est intéressant hein.
Oui. Oui. Ben évidemment. Évidemment.
Autre question d'internet. Euh le modèle
de presse indépendante,
on fait quoi ? Est-ce que la question
exacte c'est quel modèle pour une une
indépendante ? Bah
quel modèle pour une presse indépendante
? Mais que les gens acceptent de payer
pour de l'information, qu'ils
comprennent enfin que c'est pas gratuit.
parce que pardon mais euh pendant des
années, on a fait croire aux gens qu'on
pouvait faire vivre des journaux
gratuits et puis qu'on pouvait ensuite
euh aller sur internet et que le modèle
allait être immédiatement formidable et
qu'on allait pouvoir faire vivre des
vrais médias, des journalistes, des
enquêteurs, des trucs comme ça. Mais
c'est pas vrai, c'est pas gratuit. Si
quand c'est gratuit, soit vous êtes le
produit, soit c'est la pub qui vous qui
vous permet de de vivre. Et la pub, ça
permet pas d'être indépendant. Et nous
regarde.
Mais oui, mais
nous nous on a un tipi. Hop.
C'est vrai. Mais vous vous avez pas à
payer du papier, des choses comme ça.
Or, il y a des gens encore.
On a payé une équipe technique, des
locaux.
Vrai. C'est vrai. Donc peut-être que la
pièce que la presse papier va mourir.
Mais pour l'instant, il y a encore des
gens qui veulent lire sur papier.
Première chose. Deuxième chose, il faut
payer des journalistes qui fassent du
reportage, qui puissent donner à voir,
qui puissent rester sur place pendant
longtemps. Ça coûte du pognon ça aussi.
Ça coûte de l'argent d'aller voir là
quand on a fait notre numéro sur les
gilets jaunes où on est tous on a envoyé
4 5 6 journaliste dans tous les coins de
la France et ils sont restés pendant 2
jours 3 jours sur les ronds-points à
interroger les gens. Mais ça coûte de
l'argent de faire tout ça là. on le
fait, on fait ce travail là sur les
petits artisans, les petits commerçants,
les petits patrons, c'est justement ceux
qui étaient parmi les premiers gilets
jaunes pour essayer de comprendre
justement quel système ils veulent et
comment ils se font avoir souvent dans
le sens où ils demandent du libéralisme
ou leur fil du néolibéralisme qu' les
fait crever. Bon voilà, ça c'est de
l'enquête de terrain, ça prend du temps.
Bah ça coûte de l'argent.
Combien ça coûte un un un Marian papier
?
4 € on est moins cher que les autres que
les autres News magazines quoi, que les
autres hebdos. Euh dernière question
d'internet,
comment trouver une information fiable ?
La loi anticasseur, le préfet de police
alors
qui est responsable ?
Bon, on peut chois
on peut pas répondre à tout. anasseur.
Franchement, enfin on a écrit justement
dans Marian ce qu'on en pensait à savoir
que on est typiquement dans une loi qui
est profondément dangereuse. La première
la première version de la loi était
totalement délirante. L'article 2 qui
consistait à considérer que la puissance
administrative pouvait interdire de
manifester en cas de présomption de
danger, c'était dingue. C'est devenu un
tout petit peu plus précis, enfin pas
tellement plus puisque il s'agissait de
dire en cas de risque majeur si je me
souviens des termes bah de contre
l'ordre public enfin qui décide s'il y a
un risque majeur contre l'ordre public
c'estàdire que quand vous avez des
membres du gouvernement qui expliquent
que les premières manifes de gilets
jaune c'est la peste brune bah si c'est
la peste brune il y a un risque majeur
contre l'ordre public faut immédiatement
interdire donc cette cette loi est
absolument téparante.
Charles de Courson est sorti. Oui, c'est
pas un extrémiste Charles de Courson,
c'est pas voilà, c'est un type plutôt
modéré donc et après alors il y avait
une autre la première question
l'information fiable, on la trouve
comment ?
L'information fiable, on la trouve quand
il y a des gens qui signent, quand il y
a des gens qui assument. Euh après ça
dépend pas la ligue du LOL derrière avec
des points de idéologique de Casté
aussi pour les citoyens de d'adopter un
regard critique, c'est-à-dire d'abord
d'aller euh regarder un petit peu
partout pour se faire une idée.
C'est-à-dire que il faut aussi le
chercher le média qu'on veut, le média,
il faut tester. Et une fois qu'on a
testé, on sait à qui on peut faire
confiance. on sait ce qu'on accepte de
de regarder. C'est le principe en
communication de comment dire de des
abrégés de la décision. On appelle ça
comme ça. C'est en gros on n'est pas
spécialiste de tout. Donc on peut pas
savoir systématiquement si ce que disent
le le type en face est vrai ou pas. En
revanche, on connaît suffisamment de
choses quand on est bien éduqué pour
pouvoir repérer à quelques indices si le
type qu'on a en face raconte n'importe
quoi ou pas. D'où l'importance de
l'éducation au départ parce que c'est ça
qui permet de ne pas être dépendant des
discours délirants des uns et des
autres. Plus vous avez un peuple éduqué
et plus vous avez des gens qui sont
capables de détecter quand on leur
raconte des conneries. Donc ce les
médias ne peuvent vivre que de ça. On a
besoin de la confiance du lectorat.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a besoin que le
lectorat nous dise "Bon, je ne suis pas
spécialiste de ce sujet, vous m'en
parlez. Je pense que vous ne dites pas
de stupidité."
Donc ça ça se construit au long cours.
Ça veut dire qu'il ne faut jamais
décevoir son lectorat, qu'il faut jamais
se laisser aller à la facilité, qu'il
faut être extrêmement rigoureux et
nuancé. Mais ça nécessite aussi bah tout
simplement un peuple éduqué, ce qui est
la base de la démocratie. C'est des gens
capables de de distinguer. Je pense
qu'il y en a beaucoup. Je pense qu'ils
sont encore là, même si je crois qu'il y
a beaucoup à dire sur l'éducation et sur
la façon dont on
vous avez un message pour Guillaume
Meuris.
Je suis toute prête à débattre, je suis
toute prête à discuter euh avec tout le
monde. Moi, je n'ai jamais eu peur de
d'échanger des arguments. Non, parce que
j'ai cru comprendre que apparemment il
voulait pas discuter avec moi.
Non, il veut pas. Non,
ben c'est dommage.
S'il a lu le même article que nous,
c'est compréhensible. Non,
c'est-à-dire s'il a lu quel article ?
Il a pas l'air d'aimer trop Mariane.
C'est qu'il dit pas Mariane.
C'est quoi la dernière question chez
Syerview ? Je me souviens plus.
Laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Mais oui, mais je laisse tout le temps
le même. Lisez, lisez, ayez de la
curiosité. Mais enfin, il y en a un
autre aussi. Sortez dehors, regardez.
Regardez autour de vous. Il faut de la
curiosité. Moi, je crois que le le
principe pour qu'une société puisse
vivre, c'est euh cette idée de
que l'on n'est pas renfermé sur son
nombril, on vit dans une société, on vit
avec les autres. Donc on regarde autour
de soi, on s'émerveille et on regarde
les autres en face et on échange. Et ce
qui ce qu'il y a de beau, voilà, c'est
quand on construit une société où il y a
du débat. Je une société où chacun est
chez lui, commande ses trucs par
internet, va dans des boutiques où il y
a plus de caissière, où il y a plus
rien, où il y a plus de petit commerce,
c'est un cauchemar. C'est un cauchemar
absolu. Donc le débat, l'échange tout
simplement se confronter à l'autre dans
sa différence. Voilà.
Natacha Poloni, merci. Merci à vous.
Couper.
[Musique]